[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du vip cette semaine on se
retrouve avec benjamin palier benjamin
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
réalisateur oui scénariste pour le
cinéma depuis plus d'une dizaine
d'années vous anime également des
ateliers audiovisuel de doublage dans
plusieurs établissements en france et
aussi à l'étranger et vous avez commencé
à faire des vidéos très tôt est ce que
c'est une réelle passion pour vous de
l'audiovisuel bien sûr c'est une réelle
passion ce que j'ai commencé à l'âge de
9 ans au départ c'était avec mes deux
frères n'a commencé à faire des vidéos
avec une caméra vhs et ensuite nos
parents nous inscrire dans une agence
artistique pour être comédien enfants et
très vite sur le tournage d'un téléfilm
en fait je me suis aperçu que je
préférais derrière la caméra que plutôt
que devant et ensuite à l'adolescence
j'ai eu ma première caméra numérique
j'ai fait mes premiers projets avec mes
amis et à l'âge de 19 ans ensuite j'ai
fait une école de cinéma en deux ans et
par la suite j'ai monté une boîte de
production et une association
audiovisuelle qu'est ce qui vous
passionne plus dans le visuel c'est le
côté réalisation le côté montage
direction d'acteurs par exemple c'est
toute la réalisation c'est à dire de
l'écriture au montage en fait en passant
par le tournage est donc depuis vous
avez fait une quinzaine de courts
métrages deux moyens métrages des clips
musicaux des web séries donc notamment
avec alexandre gilles est donc et un peu
comédiens de doublage qui est comédien
doublage avec qui vous avez fait écho
réalisé beaucoup de projets c'est un peu
votre acolyte on va justement regardez
un extrait de votre court-métrage à mi
temps si vous voulez bien oui
[Musique]
j'oubliais
marseille jean pierre
marcelle qu'est ce que tu fais là
c'est pas ta quinzaine
et donc ses courts métrages ont eu
beaucoup de succès au final oui alors ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'à bande de
réaliser avec alexandre j'ai réalisé mes
projets tout seul et en fait j'ai vu que
j'avais quelques lacunes dans la
direction d'acteurs c'est pour ça que
j'ai fait appel à lui parce que lui les
comédiens depuis plus de 30 ans c'est un
comédien qui est très connu dans le
milieu du doublage puisque c'est la voix
de rengo sling la voix de captain
america la voix de frodon dans le
seigneur des anneaux et quand je les ai
rencontrés sur un projet de prévention
jeu les proposer en fait de co réalisé
un premier projet ensemble donc si le
film qui s'appelait goutte à goutte et
car dès le début en fait on a eu un
grand succès sur ce film on a fait une
soixantaine de festivals en france et à
l'étranger et on a eu des prix et on a
été distribué à la télévision
voilà est depuis en fait on ne se quitte
plus parce qu on est très
complémentaires c'est vrai que réalisé à
deux c'est pas évident mais on connaît
des duos très connus comme toledano et
nakache est en fait il faut être sur la
même longueur d'ondés pas se marcher sur
les pieds et pour ça nous on est très
content complémentaires lui se charge de
la mise en scène et moi plutôt de
l'aspect technique du film est là on en
est à notre cinquième court métrage 5e
qui s'appelle jackpot qui va sortir au
mois de mars et du coût auquel sont un
peu les difficultés que peut rencontrer
un jeune réalisateur vous même quelqu'un
qui veut se lancer dans le du visuel
général voilà la plus grosse faim le
plus gros souci en général c'est le côté
financier s'est trouvé de l'argent pour
pouvoir produire ses projets surtout
quand on est jeune et qu'on débute c'est
pas évident de trouver de l'argent et
donc vous êtes aussi enfin
d'inconditionnels de doublage oui vous
avez unis en ont décidé de créer une
chaîne youtube qui s'appelle les voies
éternel nos voisins comme nos voisins
éternelle où vous rendez hommage donc
une fois par semaine à des grandes voix
du doublage donc des personnes disparues
comme roger carel claude chantal
philippe dumas donc on va regarder la
bande annonce de votre votre chaîne
youtube et plaisir je veux pas lier
présente bien venue d'un nouveau
éternelle dans cette émission
hebdomadaire nous parlerons des grandes
voix du cinéma tous ces comédiens et
comédiennes sur lesquels il est
difficile de mettre un visage toutes ces
voix qui ont bercé notre enfance toutes
ces voix éternelle
chaque samedi à partir de 10h sur
youtube donc est ce que pouvait
m'expliquer un petit peu ce que vous
faites sur cette chaîne youtube alors
est ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que si on
est un grand passionné de doublage comme
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure c'est
pour ça que j'ai rencontré d'ailleurs
alexandre parce que je connaissais son
travail avant de l'avoir rencontré j'ai
également rencontré d'autres voies comme
vous avez pu l'entendre sur la bande
annonce benoît allemang et l'avoine
morgan freeman également patrick poivey
la voix de bruce willis qui
malheureusement a disparu il ya deux ans
mais aussi daniel beretta la voiture ce
n'est guère à l'intervalle la voix
stallone fin j'ai vraiment rencontré les
plus grosses voix connues du cinéma et
je me suis dit en fait ce serait pas mal
de parler de ces voix qui ont bercé
notre enfance et qui sont
malheureusement décédés aujourd'hui pour
garder une trace en fait de tout leur
travail donc c'est pour ça que moi je me
mets en scène pour faire les transitions
etc mais que j'essaie de faire des
compilations bien fournie de tout de
tout ce qu'ils ont fait en fait en
doublage c'est à dire au niveau du
dessin animé au niveau de la série et au
niveau du cinéma et pourquoi vous avait
du coup décidé de leur rendre ne le
rendre cet hommage bas parce que je suis
un passionné et d'ailleurs semaine sur
la chaîne youtube je reçois très
régulièrement des commentaires de gens
qui sont passionnés qui me lie à bata
oublie de parler le psy de paraître ça
etc mais je sais que je suis un format
court je peux pas parler de toutes les
voix que ses comédiens ont fait non je
suis un peu restreint par rapport à ça
mais en fait ça intéresse beaucoup de
monde le doublage et vous avez vous
aviez rencontré des comédiens de
doublage mais ce que vous avez du coup
travailler avec eux avec certains alors
oui bah notamment alexandre mais sinon
un d'autres sur mes projets pour des
voix off et c'est sur des projets de
prévention notamment sur un projet de
prévention sur pour l'association
laurette fugain j'avais fait appel à
daniel beretta morgan freeman un benoît
ahlmann france aux cadolles enfin tout
un tas de comédiens de doublage mais
qu'est ce qu'elle porte un comédien de
doublage un film a une série à un jeu
vidéo par exemple basquiat c'est que
leur voix nous nous marque d'ailleurs je
discutais avec certains comédiens qui me
disaient qu'ils avaient beaucoup de mal
à aujourd'hui à tournai parce qu'en fait
ça sème un espèce de trouble chez les
spectateurs ils disent mes jeux je
connais cette voie mais c'est pas lui
c'est parce comédiens là du coup ils ont
beaucoup de mal c'est ses comédiens de
doublage spéciales et de spécialités
dans le doublage de faire autre chose
que du doublage ou du théâtre parce que
ça ça m'intrigue chez les spectateurs
donc voilà mais aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
c'est un peu la mode delà de la vo comme
on dit la version originale est ce que
vous auriez un présente un exemple de
films ou de séries qui est meilleur on
va dire doubler que quand version
originale alors meilleur je sais pas
mais je trouve que les comédiens on a de
très bons comédiens de doublage en
france
ça faut le noter il faut un très gros
travail en général quand ils sont
recrutés c'est ce que me disait
alexandre j'ai justement il faut savoir
pour le seigneur des anneaux par exemple
il a été recruté par peter jackson en
personne en fait en peter jackson c'est
un réalisateur qui casse toutes les voix
de tous les pays dans lequel le film a
été exploitée de tous les personnages
donc ça fait un certain nombre de
personnages notamment pour seigneur des
anneaux mais
mais voilà en fait ils essayent de que
la voix française soit au plus proche de
la voix originale
après c'est tout un travail de comédien
et de directeurs artistiques sur le
plateau pour diriger ses comédiens de
façon à ce que la voie soit le plus
proche de la version originale mais par
exemple le seigneur des anneaux moi je
trouve ça un film qui est aussi bien en
vf et en vo et qu'elle vous avez parlé
de beaucoup de comédiens de doublage
quel serait votre voir préférer toutes
générations confondues on va dire pour
moi c'est benoît hellman la voix de
morgan freeman
parce que quand j'étais gamin je
regardais beaucoup de disney dans sur
les cassettes vhs que je mettais dans
magnétoscope et en fait il faisait
toutes les bandes annonces qui précédait
le dessin animé et c'est une voix qui
m'a marqué et qui me marquent encore moi
j'ai eu la chance de travailler avec lui
je suis très content et donc vous
arrêtez pas là puisque vous aimez aussi
partager un petit peu vos passions vous
travaillez beaucoup avec les enfants
vous êtes d'ailleurs aussi éducateur
notamment vous travaillez sous forme
d'ateliers de salage d'audiovisuel vous
avez réalisé la websérie osef la série
par exemple qui a du succès sur internet
et beaucoup de succès cette saison oui
bon année à 350 millions à 150 millions
sur l'ensemble de la chaîne j'ai eu il
ya eu aussi des célébrités qui avait
cave adams je croyais voilà qui est
madame ce qu'a fait c'est un petit
soutien que je connais qu'à madame
depuis sept huit ans
quand ils n'étaient pas encore connues
il est aussi mohamed qu'ici qu'un
comédien qui a joué pour ceux qui
connaissent dans les films de van damme
qui faisait le rôle de tout repos dans
le film kick boxer et puis d'autres
personnalités eric judor de eric et
ramzy qui nous a fait un petit soutien
aussi parce que son père avait travaillé
dans l'établissement où je travaille
donc il avait un certain lien avec cet
établissement donc un beau succès pour
cette série parce qu'on voit là on parle
de la vie au collège ça parle aux jeunes
et ça parle un peu à tout le monde ça
fait revenir les gens dans leur enfance
en fait et c'est important pour vous du
coup cette transmission avec les enfants
c'est très important d'ailleurs moi
c'est ma passion c'est de transmettre ma
passion aux jeunes en fait et d'ailleurs
le pour petite anecdote le personnage de
martin dans joseph quel rôle principal
de la série suit à 7
à ces productions de osef la web série
est bien il ya deux agents artistiques
qui ont voulu le recruter pour ensuite
qu'ils participent phase des castings et
ou dans différents projets artistiques
donc il a appuyé tourner aide pour les
oléo mattei avec jean luc reichmann il a
tourné sur france 4 donc quelque part je
suis c'est un peu une fierté pour moi de
voir que grâce à certains de mes projets
ensuite ça peut ouvrir des portes pour
l'avenir de certains jeunes qu'est-ce
que qu'est ce que ça leur rapporte c'est
des ateliers dont kisai ils font un peu
tout ils font là la caméra vous avez du
matériel on a tout le matériel
alors il ya des comètes des des enfants
qui préfère être devant la caméra
d'autres qui préfèrent être derrière
alors derrière ça peut être tenir la
caméra tenir la perche
enregistrer le son faire le clap gérait
la lumière donc tous les postes sont
répartis bien avant avec un calendrier
et puis après devant la caméra il nous
répartissions des rôles ont fait un
petit casting en début d'année et puis
on répartit les rôles selon le niveau de
jeu de chacun en fait et vous qu'est ce
que ça vous a peur de faire sa ba ça ça
m'apporte que je suis fière de
transmettre ma passion aux jeunes voilà
parce que je trouve que c'est c'est bien
de faire partager tout ça aux jeunes la
vidéo je pense que c'est un outil qui va
être de plus en plus utilisés
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs les jeunes en
font la vidéo tous les jours sur les
réseaux sociaux donc c'est bien aussi de
canaliser sa avec un vrai projet et puis
une vraie organisation derrière c'est
pas trop compliqué du coup de jongler
entre votre métier de visuels il ya le
côté éducateurs pas ce qui est bien
c'est que j'ai la chance de travailler
dans un établissement donc je peux
intervenir avec des maternelles des
primaires des collèges et du lycée
mais toutes les vacances je suis
tranquille donc ça me permet de faire
mes projets personnels pendant les
vacances en fait donc c'est pour ça que
les deux métiers se goupille bien et du
coup vous avez habité aussi longtemps à
rambouillet et vous entend vous
intervenez au collège de s'intéressent
d'ailleurs tous vos projets audiovisuels
sont plus ou moins tourné dans les
alentours est ce que c'est important
pour vous ce territoire ah ouais c'est
très important d'ailleurs je mets
souvent la flore est à l'honneur dans
mes projets parce que la forêt de
rambouillet est vaste et on peut y
retourner plein de projets
et puis rambouillet pareil le
centre-ville le manège certains certains
lieux de du centre-ville de rambouillet
sont très importants pour moi qu'est ce
que vous trouvez du coup dans ces
paysages des yvelinois bas je trouve que
enfin notamment pour la forêt c'est un
lieu vaste où on peut y faire plein de
choses voilà tout simplement et puis
c'est un décor qui est juste à côté qui
est gratuit fin j'ai plein de davantage
on va dire il faut savoir jusqu'où dans
le que je me disais dans le dans l'audio
visuel il faut savoir se trouvaient
d'autres casquettes par exemple est ce
que là vous avez d'autres projets à
venir alors là il ya donc elle cinquième
court métrage qui s'appelle jackpot
qu'on a réalisé avec alexandre gillet
qui va sortir au mois de mars qu'on va
envoyer dans plein de festivals comme on
a fait pour tous les autres d'ailleurs
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que le
processus d'un court métrage on ne fait
pas un court métrage pour gagner de
l'argent clairement on en perd
d'ailleurs en produisant
le but après 7 c est essayer de se faire
connaître donc pour ensuite pour voir
faire un long métrage écrire tourner et
monter un long métrage donc on va
l'envoyer dans plein de festivals on va
essayer de trouver un distributeur pour
nous distribuer sur différentes chaînes
de télé qui diffuse des courts métrages
notamment orange cinéma canal+ enfin de
tout ce genre de toutes ces chaînes
donc le cinquième court métrage est
ensuite bas nous l'idée c'est de passer
un long maintenant ça fait cinq courts
métrages qu'on fait ensemble avec
alexandre maintenant on a envie de
vraiment de produire enfin de réaliser
un long métrage qui est déjà en cours de
création instaurant cherchons voilà on
cherchait une idée à écrire
c'est qu'on aura la bonne idée on va se
mettre à écrire parce que dans le but
après in fine et ce serait de pouvoir
envisage d'arrêter mon boulot
d'éducateurs même si j'adore transmettre
aux élèves mais de faire plus que ça
mais ça ne s'est pas évident mais dans
le milieu audiovisuel de de vivre de sa
passion il faut savoir faire plusieurs
choses justement c'est sa faute à
couteau suisse un couteau suisse
c'est un très beau parcours en tout cas
nous c'est la fin de ce fait y paie qui
vous étaient consacre consacrée
n'hésitez pas à aller sur la chaîne
youtube novo éternelle pour en apprendre
un peu plus sur ces grandes voix avec
benjamin palier quant à nous on se
retrouve pour une émission à très vite
merci
[Musique]